can you cup holder JLo's night out with
her new man everyone I'm Denny direct oh
and here's what's trending on et now
jennifer lopez and longtime
choreographer jr. taylor were snapped
leaving craig's restaurant in west
hollywood the Jenny from the block
singer posted this video showing off her
Footwear and flawless makeup for the
duo's night out night out with the
bestie bestie so who is junior while the
two have worked together for quite some
time you actually worked on this Coast
commercial that also featured her ex
Casper Smart Jennifer Lopez is the best
dancer he's also a model and this isn't
the first time the sexy pair have been
spotted together just last month he
celebrated Jennifer's 45th birthday
posted this photo on instagram with the
caption blow out your candles baby
tonight belongs to you hashtag happy
birthday at June JLo definitely loves
her dancers the singer of course was
once married a choreographer Chris Judd
dated dancer choreographer Casper Smart
for over three years and was rumored to
be dating dancing with the stars pro
Maksim Chmerkovskiy what do you guys
think do you think JLo has a type
treating the @d directo use the hashtag
DC now and keep it locked on etonline as
we track this trending story and more